على الرغم من اشتعال الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
في فرنسا ضد خطط الحكومه برفع سن التقاعد
وتاثير تلك المظاهرات السلبيه على
الاقتصاد يصر الرئيس ماكرون على مواجهه
المحتجين متسلحا بان نظام التقاعد الحالي
غير مستدام وسينهار اذا ما بقي على حاله
فنظام التقاعد الفرنسي يعاني من ضغوط
كبيره ابرزها ارتفاع معدل الشيخوخه
فالافراد يعيشون لسن اكبر في وقت يقل عدد
الموظفين الصغار سنا ففي ستينات القرن
الماضي كان هناك اكثر من اربعه موظفين
مقابل كل متقاعد مقارنه بموظف فاصل سبعه
لكل متقاعد في 2020 وهناك توقعات بوصول
هذا المعدل الى موظف فاصل اثنين لكل
متقاعد في عشرين سبعين وهذا يعني ان
النظام التقاعد الحالي لن يصمد ماليا لوقت
طويل فلن تكون هناك اموال موظفين تكفي
لدفع مرتبات التقاعد لكبار السن
مكروه يهدف بهذا التعديل لخفض العجز
المالي من مستوى الخمسه في المئه من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الى مستهدفات
الاتحاد الاوروبي عند ثلاثه في المئه
ففرنسا تدفع اكثر من 14% من ناتجها المحلي
الاجمالي لبرامج التقاعد في حين تخصص
امريكا سبعه ونصف في المئه فقط لها
و10.4% في المانيا وفي ظل الوضع الحالي
لنظام التقاعد الفرنسي من المتوقع ان يصل
العجز في النظام الى مليار وثمائه مليون
يورو هذا العام ليرتفع الى 10.7 مليار في
عشرين خمسه وعشرين واكثر من 21 مليارا في
عشرين خمسه وثلاثين
[تصفيق]
وتاتي المواجهات بين الحكومه ونقابات
العمال في فرنسا على الرغم من ارتفاع نسبه
ضرائب الدخل في البلاد فالبلاد تحتل
المرتبه الثانيه بين دول منظمه التعاون
الاقتصادي والتنميه على قائمه اعلى معدلات
الضرائب الى الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بنسبه
تتجاوز
45% شادي الزعيم العربيه